he's Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the
third NBA on TNT analyst and he's got
the call this Thursday night Oklahoma
City visits the Nuggets at 10:30 Eastern
on TNT reg how are you I'm very well
Theodore good morning to you as well as
to my Danette Eric Bledsoe has been
traded to the Milwaukee Bucks Greg
Monroe and a draft pick what does this
mean to either one of these teams well I
think for Milwaukee you get a top-flight
point guard as much as I love last
year's Rookie of the Year Malcolm
Brogdon and two years they picked up
Matthew Dellavedova or signed him to a
contract both of those guys are great
backups at least you get a top-flight
starting point guard what remains to be
seen is because young young has opted to
come Powe handles the basketball I would
say 80 to 85 percent of the time which
is why he needs the Bucks in every
statistical category to me I always
thought that you needed a point guard
who was a great shooter a point guard
who could compost up in those corners
and when he and when Jana
you know penetrates he can find the
point guard and he can knock down shots
that's what Brogdon does and that's what
Dellavedova does well that's not the
Eric Bledsoe his game
he needs the basketball to be successful
and he's had a great shooter but he's a
great athlete so it just remains to be
seen how Jason Kidd is going to
integrate him into this office where
Yanis handles the basketball the
majority of the time you've got Oklahoma
City against the Nuggets coming up on
Thursday night I saw you tweet after
Carmelo Anthony got tossed from the game
the other night and you thought it was
as bad a call as you've seen in a long
long time why was he talking to you I
have no idea and they're saying that
when he went on the drive that he was
seeking out Newark egde and every person
especially scorers who are taught
you want to fill the contact especially
when you're going to the hole you want
that body contact a lot of players like
to shy away from it but the great ones
seek out that contact not to hurt anyone
but you need to use especially for bigs
you need to use their own size against
them and if you look at that play he had
both hands on the basketball and the
play it was a foul on the play on Newark
it was supposed to be an an yeah yeah
the ball went in I was shocked and once
again I know everyone says well isn't it
great that the officials have the
opportunity to go to the review Center
and look at replays to get the call
right I get that but we saw it last
night too
Steph Curry got a technical foul going
to the hole on a left-hand layup and
that his follow through his right arm I
can't remember whose face that he hit
maybe it was Goran Dragic he gets a
technical foul you've got to let common
sense and you've got to let your natural
body I mean to me that was a natural
play by Carmelo that's why I said this
NBA is soft now because everything if
that was the case Charles Oakley
Grandmamma Larry Johnson Anthony Mason
all those times I went to the hole
against New York and they used to pull
me upside down
they've got to be cringing right now
that you have the potential to be thrown
out of a game for a foreign and one on
Carmelo it just it just made me sick to
my stomach
is it working in Oklahoma City with Paul
George and airing and Melo in there with
Russell Westbrook again there's only one
team that's an outlier in this in this
league and that's to go and say warriors
because they have the chemistry and
they're well coached and they have the
horses to play any kind of style you
want and chemistry is huge and you asked
me this last week about Cleveland and
this is the same case for OKC it's going
to take a while to get Paul George and
Carmelo Anthony on the same page with
Russell Westbrook and their style of
play and that's a challenge for Billy
Donovan and his coaching staff it's
great to have those
in your system but it's gonna take time
for that chemistry to work and we're
kind of seeing that right now but I
think in time that's why I'm not overly
concerned about a fender just like I'm
not overly concerned about the Cavaliers
though I will say this because it's
still too early for the Cavs in the
immortal words of Michael Sugar Ray
Richardson this [ __ ] be sinking a little
bit in Cleveland because you guys guys
kind of fight that one you know Dwayne
Wade calling out the starters I mean I
look I'm gonna give them a free pass
because excuse me at the end of the day
they have LeBron James as well as long
as he's healthy he can write the ship
but I don't like the fighting and
another thing I don't like usually your
defense is ahead of your offense the
start of the season it takes a while for
your office and your legs to get into it
but your defense should always be
constant the calves are terrible at the
defensive end yeah that's what would
concern me the most
Reggie's calling Oklahoma City and the
Denver Nuggets 10:30 Eastern on TNT this
Thursday night but this would make for
an easier exit for LeBron James
considering the way this team is playing
right it would and I'm sure the
questions will start just because he's
been non-committal after this season is
you gonna stay with the Cavs or is he
gonna shop his talents elsewhere but
again I will say this we are only what
two and a half three weeks into the
season and just like I'm not overly like
oh my god the Boston Celtics are the
best team and there was earned in the
Eastern Conference what they are they've
won about eight straight mm-hmm so the
record says that but I'm it's three
weeks in and there's a lot of time left
and those moving parts and those new
players that the Cavs have it's gonna
take some time talk to me January 1st
and going forward if this is the same
thing that's continuing to go on
terrible defense that one in and my turn
your turn basketball for the Cavs then
that's a different discussion
the things I'm looking at Ben Simmons
he's playing 36 minutes Lonzo ball I
think his second with 33 minutes what do
you think of those minutes for a rookie
because I I saw where Lanza is dad said
that he should be playing more I think
he might be talking about should be
playing more down the stretch in the
fourth quarter but what is a
considerable amount of time for a rookie
to be playing reg well both of those
players are the faces of their franchise
and if you get 30 plus minutes as a
rookie that's outstanding it doesn't
matter if it's you know 30 31 or 36 37
like Ben Simmons if you get 30 plus
minutes in any NBA game you're averaging
that as a rookie I mean that's fantastic
I believe my rookie year I averaged 1213
minutes maybe so if you can get 30 plus
minutes as a rookie in this league
you're doing something kristaps
porzingis the other night I'm watching
and he's not doing anything against
Indiana and then I flip back on and he's
lighting up the Pacers in the fourth
quarter ends up with 40 reg I mean yeah
what is reasonable what if you're a
Knicks fan what is reasonable to expect
from porzingis this season well
certainly an all-star he will certainly
be get his first all-star nod but
remember the comments good old Phil
Jackson saying you couldn't build a team
around him and that's what kind of
ticked him off and why he didn't show up
for his exit meeting I think I was
trying to show his daughters that he can
be a go-to guy and I kind of mentioned
this on-air when we did their game that
first weekend of opening night versus
OKC I wanted to see you once the double
and triple teams come because Carmelo
Anthony got all those well now that
you're the man and you're gonna get
those double and triple teams how are
you gonna handle them he's still not a
great passer but he's becoming much
better and he's coming to a more willing
passer and you know guys are making
shots and his confidence is growing
right in front of us and on the biggest
stage which is New York so certainly
he'll be he'll make the all-star team
but I think his the bigger goals for him
is to try to get New York especially in
the Eastern Conference into the play
that would be a huge challenge but it's
doable in the East but you look at the
the foreign-born players you know you
got the two leading scorers are from you
know people who players who didn't play
in the United States play their college
ball there with porzingis a Greek freak
there is there a choice I mean one is
1:21 the other ones 22 could we be
looking at the two best players in the
game five years from now being these two
guys who weren't you know that are
foreign-born we certainly can and it
shows the diversity of the game of
basketball and how much it's grown and
you can really attribute that to the
original dream team and that success
they had when they went over there and
Barcelona and I think young kids saw
that and they saw the success and now
we're seeing the fruits of the labor of
that if you could have porzingis or
anthony davis right now and you got him
for a max deal i would still go with
anthony davis my only concern with
anthony davis you did say anthony davis
yeah you know those injuries no scare me
it's the injury scare me yeah but I
still think Anthony Davis is a much
better defender he's not the shooter
that porzingis is but i think he's a
better score and all-around player and
athlete but porzingis is a pretty he
could block shots as well wow that's a
good call I'm still gonna go with
Anthony Davis but the injuries there
they're starting to mount up I know I
know he's great but I don't know if he's
gotten that much better here in the last
two years because of those injuries but
if I said you could have alread Freaker
Anthony Davis who you take this kid is
he's gonna be in rarefied air here in a
minute he really is he is that special
if I said you could have the Greek freak
er Steph Curry the next five years
the Greek Creek because he's younger
he's 21 22 Steph is 29 steps in his
prime yes but the Greek freak has not
even scratched the surface yet we
haven't seen the best of him yet and
that's what's scary we were saying the
same thing about Kevin Durant to me it's
how it's how your peers view you for
Kevin Durant to say this dude is the
next big thing yeah we were saying that
about you my friend yeah we were that
about you for Kevin Durant to say that
I'm gonna follow his lead he's Reggie
Aloysius Miller jr. the third he's got
Oklahoma City and the Denver Nuggets
coming up Thursday night on TNT at 10:30
Eastern reg safe travels as always and
we'll talk to you soon
see you door I liked your conversation
with Will Ferrell I mean you're gonna
he's gonna get you out on the they gonna
get on the bike and start you know going
out with him and Roedean and mountain I
mean that's you right I think you a boom
baby jersey you have your boom baby
jersey ready I'm more of a stationary
bike guy oh you like a peloton yeah or
SoulCycle okay okay yeah so will will
wants to come over to my house and we
can get on stationary bicycles and wear
bike shorts that they own that'd be
great that's what we might do also is
just the bike shorts that are holding
you back you don't want to be in public
with them no no I like them oh yeah I
like I wear them even when I'm not on a
bike I'll wear my bike shorts
[Music]
thank you buddy
Reggie Aloysius Miller for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]